most of my movies have been a reflection
of things that happened to me
these are dreams
[Music]
and the story kept tugging me back to
actual memories and seeing them unspool
in front of me it was just like nothing
I have ever gone through before and
ultimately it was a very good experience
so soon two years after my father passed
away and five years after my mom died in
this family it's the scientists versus
the artists Sammy's on my team takes
after me Steven said it's about his
childhood how he grew up and his
memories of his parents and his sisters
spent playing in deep imagination kind
of movies you dismissed what he does
it's playful or imaginative we wanted to
make a movie that reflected a human
experience that's familiar and something
that would say something about life I
wanted people to see their own families
inside the story because this story is
about family and it's about parents it's
about siblings it's about bullying it's
about the good and bad things that
happen when you're growing up in a
family that stays together until they're
no longer together you always have to be
the center of attention stop shouting at
her that has been nothing but disrespect
from you I'm Your Mother
in this film he is letting you into how
he sees the world which is Cinematic and
wondrous but ultimately the film goes
beyond Stephen where there's something
in it for anyone who's had a family for
anyone that's loved the movies for
anybody who's dared to dream big family
hot
it'll tear you into
and he would show up on set see us in
our wardrobes and you can see it just
hit something in his brain and he would
just start crying you stopped making
movies that'll break your mother's heart
and it really emphasized how personal it
was and how special it was to him and
how vulnerable he was in a lot of ways
you can't not something you also have to
take care of it it's more important than
your hobby can you stop calling it a
hobby if this was any film it would have
been a very impactful learning
experience for me but the fact that it
was a Steven Spielberg film and the fact
that it meant even more to him than it
did myself I'm very grateful to be a
part of that I don't know what to do
anymore
you do what your heart says you have to
I cannot even imagine going through my
career without having told this story
this movie for me was like a time
machine in the sense of the fablements
wasn't about metaphor it was about
memory what was your favorite part
[Music]